[موسيقى]
صباح الخميس 26 من الشهر الحالي اقتحمت
قوه اسرائيليه خاصه مخيمه جنين متخفيه في
سياره فلسطين
الهدف خلايا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في
المخيم يقول الاحتلال انها نفذت عمليات ضد
اهداف اسرائيليه وتنميه تنفيذ عمليات اخرى
في العمق الاسرائيلي مجموعه من المقاومه
اكتشفت امر القوه الاسرائيليه اشتبكت معها
سقطت تسعه شهداء بعد ساعات انطلق صاروخان
من قطاع غزه اسرائيل باستهداف مواقع
للمقاومه
للطائرات الحربيه باسلحه مضاده للطائرات
بعد 24 ساعه وصل الشاب خيري علقا من سكان
حي الطور بالقدس المحتله الى مدخل الحي
للسيطاني لبيع يعقوب من جهه بلده بيت
حنينا اطلق النار على مستوطنين امام كنيس
يهوديه في الحي فقتل سبعه منهم وجرح اخرين
قبل ان يستشهد في المكان بعد ساعات نفذ
الفتاه محمد عليوات عمليه اطلاق نار لمسدس
في بلده سلوان جنوب المسجد الاقصى المبارك
اصاب اثنين احدهما في حاله حرجه اطلق جندي
النار على الفتى الفلسطيني فاصابه
واعتقالته قوات الاحتلال
الان تتجه نحو المناطق الشماليه للضفه
الغربيه جنين ومخيمها ونابلس والبلده
القديمه فيها في مخيم جنين تتحسن مجموعات
للمقاومه ابرزها كتيبه جميله التابعه
لسرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي لكنها كما تقول تقاتل بجانب
مسلحين من كتائب القسام وكتائب شهداء
الاقصى في البلده القديمه بنابلس تتحسن
مجموعه وبعدين الاسود وهي المجموعات التي
تضم عشرات المقاتلين الذين لا ينتمون لاي
من الفصائل الفلسطينيه تمكنت قوات
الاحتلال من قتل عدد من قادتها لكن
المجموعه تؤكد مواصله تنفيذ عمليات ضد
اهداف اسرائيليه في المنطقه اسرائيل
تتواعد وهي تقف على مفترق طرق امام تصاعدي
دائره التوتر عينها على المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه واخرى على
قطاع غزه وخصائله المسلحه الداخل
الاسرائيلي يزداد توتر واستقطابا يكثف
الضغط على حكومه نتنياهو واقطع بها
المتطرفه